[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
have you seen these images well it may
surprise you but they could have been
Buenos Aires in June 1806 the then
capital of the Viceroy of the Rio de La
Plata was invaded by the English who
after a couple of months were expelled
the following year the same situation
rose again with the same result so today
the joke among some argentines is that
had it not been for the heroic action of
the Creoles Argentina could be like
Australia Today of course people never
really know what would have happened and
of course if history tells us anything
is that the successes or failure of a
country depends above all on the
institutions that would have been
implemented
in the case of Argentina which we have
talked about so many times here before
is a good proof about this we have made
a lot of videos about Argentina but we
were missing one key issue looking at
the state this country is in today it
may seem like a myth almost a martian
science fiction story but the truth is
that there was a time when Argentina was
a very wealthy country one of the
richest countries is in the world maybe
even the richest of all the question is
how is this possible was Argentina
really such a rich place and if so why
on Earth was it so different from the
country we find today and another very
important question given the allergy
that Argentine politicians currently
have to international trade and foreign
Capital what role did they play in that
supposed Golden Era well let's find out
the origin of a Nation
at the end of the 18th century the
Spanish Crown decided to create the
vicer royalty of the Rio de Plata
placing the capital in the city of
Buenos Aires at that time in this remote
and sparsely inhabitated region was not
particularly interesting for the Spanish
Empire however English smuggling and
Portuguese expansion from Brazil made
the crown take notice of this place and
they began to care more about it hence
they decided to establish a more
significant presence in the region
however the decline of the Empire the
poor economic health the occupation of
Spain by Napoleon strips and the spread
of the Enlightenment triggered
Independence movements in practically
all the American territories of the
Empire between 1810 and 1825 with the
sole exception of Cuba and Puerto Rico
and so among the separatist territories
was what we now know today as Argentina
was on the 25th of May 1810 deposed
Viceroy cinderos to proclaim a local
government let's just say that the
formal excuse was that with the King of
Spain imprisoned by Napoleon power was
returning to the people which is six
years later on the 9th of July 1816.
Argentina declared its definitive
Independence although it hardly brought
peace conflicts and local Wars followed
one after the other at stake were those
who would occupy the government and what
kind of government would be established
fundamentally there was two great
factions the unitaros and the federales
you see the conflict was very much
determined by the power that Buenos
Aires accumulated over the rest of the
provinces as Buenos Aires had a port in
customs which were two main sources of
wealth this territory considered that
they ought to have more rights than the
rest of them for their part the
provinces of the Interior argued that
these resources belonged to everyone and
that they should be shared equally and
that there should be no extraordinary
rights in any case the conflict dragged
on for almost 50 years the dispute was
only finally resolved in the middle of
the 19th century when the constitution
of 1853 was approved and the City of
Buenos Aires was federalized in 1880.
but you know what after the proclamation
of independence the approval of this
constitution was something like the
second founding moment of Argentina
[Music]
it was from that moment when Argentina
really began to be built and when the
institutions that completely changed the
country and put it on the road to being
one of the leading places in the world
began to be set up and guess what this
is where one of the key names in
Argentine history appears Juan Bautista
alberty who was considered the father of
the Constitution even though he did not
participate in the constituent
convention in charge of the writing of
the Constitution however he did publish
a book entitled bases and starting
points for the political organization of
the Argentine Republic which was the
work that influenced the Constitution
basically you could say that it laid the
foundation stones but why are we telling
you this here on visualpolitik well
because in this work alberty explains
the obstacles that the country faced in
order to achieve development
because at that time Argentina did not
have precious metals nor a large
population nor was it close to the
developed world so it needed a very
competitive political framework that
would allow the country to join the
Second Industrial Revolution along these
lines alberty identified four main
obstacles that had to be overcome in
order to leave poverty behind and really
take off number one lack of capital
number two the scarcity of population
keep in mind that at that time Argentina
was practically an uninhabited place
with barely 2 million people number
three lack of infrastructure and finally
the lack of legal certainty especially
in terms of guaranteeing private
property and freedom of Enterprise that
was number four I don't know it might
almost seem that we are talking about
the 21st century but the truth is that
we are talking about the 19th century
you can see that many of the problems
are repeated over and over again in fact
we could almost say that in many
respects today's Argentina has gone back
in time almost 200 years but let's not
get sidetracked
[Music]
foreign
the point is that all these concerns
were reflected in the constitution of
1853 which gave a free hand to the
arrival of foreign investments and
immigrants guaranteed private property
and promoted the development of
railroads and so with the new
constitution during the time of the
first three presidents of Argentina the
country began to prosper a process that
accelerated after 1880 when the country
was completely pacified the city of
Buenos Aires was integrated as a federal
capital and Patagonia was incorporated
from that moment on the period of
greatest economic growth in the
country's history began we are talking
about a process that lasted more than 50
years and it would Place Argentina among
the 10 richest and most prosperous
countries in the world in the first
decade of the 20th century at that time
the Argentine dream was the equivalent
of the American dream
[Music]
in less than four decades the country
had become one of the world's leading
food producers with nearly 12 million
hectares planted 5 million tons of
grains exported and millions of head of
cattle and that was not all the country
also has some of the most modern
infrastructure in the world with large
ports Urban tramways and 28 000
kilometers of Railways running
throughout the country now at this point
the question we have to ask ourselves is
exactly how did Argentina change and
what made its economy take off to become
one of the richest and most prosperous
in the world can we find any concrete
example of all this Prosperity the truth
is that we can highlight four major
changes that marked a turning point stay
tuned because next we're going to see
exactly how this country changed this is
an example of what can be achieved in
just a few years check this out
dream Target
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
following alberti's principles the
constitution of 1853 not only opened the
doors to immigration but also promoted
it with the idea of populating a
gigantic territory that was practically
deserted and so between the end of the
19th and the beginning of the 20th
century millions and millions of
Europeans arrived in search of a better
life to give you an idea Argentina was
the second favorite destination for
Europeans only after the United States
from the beginning of the 20th century
emigration was constantly increasing
Spaniards Italians Germans Greeks and a
lot of other nationalities in 1905 the
population was already just over 5
million 800 000 inhabitants and yet in
just six years it grew by another
million
why are you going to Argentina well just
like everyone else to see if I can get
out of poverty dialogue between
political law professor Adolfo Posada
and a Spanish immigrant in 1910. the
question is what exactly did the country
have to offer well besides a lot of work
there were also much higher salaries
for example thanks to the enormous
Prosperity that was pumping the salaries
received by spanish immigrants in
Argentina was three times higher than
the salaries they received in Spain and
in the case of the Italians they were
double of course not everything was
still wonderful hard work and social
protests were the order of the day but
naturally given the facts in hand it's
not surprising that when an immigrant
arrived they soon convinced their
relatives and friends to pack all their
bags and move to the Argentine dream as
well and this caused not only the
country's population to Skyrocket but
also grew much faster than the
populations of countries like Australia
or Canada surprised well let's go on
[Music]
the arteries of a new power
[Music]
another of the great changes and at the
same time one of the factors that
boosted the economy was the development
of a modern railroad network of course
it's such a vast country with very few
navigable Rivers the railroad was a key
piece of infrastructure for transporting
dudes quickly and cheaply the good news
is that at the time the country's
leaders were very clear about this soon
thousands and thousands of miles of
lines began to be built between 1865 and
1910 the railway Network Grew From less
than 500 kilometers 310 miles to more
than 30 000 kilometers over 18 000 miles
the tracks linked to Bolivia with Prieto
de cedo the Andes with the Atlantic and
the humid Pampers with the port of
Buenos Aires which is where almost 80
percent of international trade entered
and left to give you an idea in 1910
Argentina was ranked number 10 in the
world in terms of railroad progress and
take note that in relation to the
surface area the Argentine network was
larger than the network in Canada or
Australia but that's not the end of it
let's continue
[Music]
the roulette of prosperity
[Music]
another change was the enormous
expansion of the Argentine economy this
we have already said in a way is the
subject of this video but just how
prosperous was Argentina well you see
according to Angus Madison's estimates
by the 1910 only seven countries in the
entire world were more prosperous
Belgium Switzerland Great Britain and
the four historic British colonies and
their economic successes Canada
Australia the United States and New
Zealand in fact briefly between 1895 and
1896 it was considered the richest
country in the world and so in 1909 for
example Argentina's per capita income
was 50 higher than that of Italy 180
higher than that of Japan and almost
five times higher than that of
neighboring Brazil but do you want more
data of course you do so check this out
in that same year of 1910 Argentina was
the world's leading exporter of wheat
corn beef mutton and lamb and womb
between 1900 and 1913 and this is
important Argentine exports represented
2.1 percent of the total of all Global
exports and in 1909 they reached 2.6 by
comparison the same period of time
Australia only had a share of 1.5 what a
difference to put it simply Argentina
was flying high the countryside made the
country an agricultural power the cities
did not stop expanding and at the same
time services and Industry just kept
growing as well but way a moment because
we still have to highlight one last
great change that took place in the
country a change that made Argentina a
leader in a field that I'm sure you
would never have thought of
[Music]
the Argentine brain
[Music]
in the second half of the 19th century
Argentina made an enormous effort in
education during that time hundreds of
schools were founded and even
educational professionals were brought
from the United States and that's not
all in 1882 president giulio Roca
enacted the law known as law 1420 on
primary education a law that established
free compulsory and secular education
keep in mind that this was very rare at
the time so it's not surprising that
schools and institutes suddenly began to
sprout like mushrooms all over the
country thanks to this in just six
decades between 1869 and 1939 illiteracy
was reduced to less than a fifth from 70
to less than 20 percent and okay I know
that today this figure means seemed very
high however we have to remember what
era we're talking about for example
while in 1914 in Argentina 35 of the
population did not know how to read or
write at that same time in Spain that
figure reached no less than 59 percent
[Music]
then in addition university studies also
became much more popular than was common
in Europe in other words Argentina was
growing in production in population and
infrastructure and also in education and
it did so much more than European
countries and the vast majority of
countries in the world at the time do
you remember the joke we talked about at
the beginning of this video about the
English invasion of Buenos Aires well
the truth is that it didn't need any
help at the beginning of the 20th
century Argentina was already like
Australia the Argentine Capital Buenos
Aires was even known as the Paris of
South America unfortunately however this
Prosperity did not last long and here I
think a picture is worth a thousand
words take a look at this it was not a
myth that country really did exist the
Argentina of successes was a reality
the process took them about a hundred
years first they gained independence
from Spain at that time the territory
was very poor and then they needed 50
years to enact their constitution and
get things going and then another 50
years until they recorded their Peak
between the end of the 19th century and
the beginning of the 20th century but
why did it all turn around we've
answered that question for you in a
bunch of videos here on visualpolitik
but for now it's over to you do you
think Argentina will shine again someday
what do you think has to happen for
prosperity to return to the country
leave us your answer in the comments
below and if you found this video
interesting don't forget to give us a
like subscribe and hit the little bell
button down there so you don't miss any
of our updates thank you very much for
watching all the best and I'll see you
next time
[Music]